Luffy’s biggest failure was letting his
brother Ace die during the war at Marineford.
But since that catastrophic defeat, Luffy
has grown into one of the strongest characters
in the story.
Which makes me wonder, could Luffy have saved
Ace if he had ALL of his powers from the current
story?
So in this video, we are going to give Luffy
a chance to see if he can turn this [show
Ace dying with Akainu’s fist] into this
[show thumbnail again].
To start things off, just like in the original
story Luffy arrives after the battle has already
started.
And basically everything leading up the war
remains the same.
The Whitebeard pirates have clashed with the
marines and Luffy is falling towards Whitebeard’s
ship.
Only
this time, the former strongest man alive
senses that Luffy is not just some random
kid falling from the sky.
Instead, Whitebeard senses a threat and swings
his blade with a fully charged conqueror’s
haki blast just like he did against Roger.
Luffy blocks with his own conqueror’s infused
sandals, and their epic clash splits the skies
[can you make something like when roger clashed
with whitebeard in ch 966].
After this initial clash, they quickly figure
out that they are both here to save Ace and
decide to team up, just like they did in the
original Marineford.
But before we see how Gear 5 Luffy would completely
flip this battle on its head, you might want
to ask, Manu, how in the world would it even
be possible for Luffy to have awakened Gear
5 this early in the story?
Well, there are few plausible options.
For example, Luffy could have unlocked Gear
5 after nearly dying in underwater prison
Impel Down.
Or he could have met someone else in the Grand
Line who taught him the secrets of his devil
fruit.
But since the main point of this video is
to see how current storyline Luffy would do
at Marineford, I’ll say ‘don’t worry
about it’.
We’ll just assume that he has awakened his
fruit SOMEHOW, that Ace is still captured,
and that everything else is basically the
same from the original story.
Because, as you’d expect, just this one
change alone is going to make the outcome
insanely different.
This time Luffy will have no trouble getting
past the common marines and vice-admirals.
With a single blast of conqueror’s haki,
he knocks out most of the marines and heads
right for his brother Ace.
And in this version of the war, Luffy will
likely still clash with the strongest swordsman
in the world, Mihawk.
Originally, the warlord wanted to test himself
against Whitebeard, so he would definitely
want to clash against this overpowered Luffy.
So can Mihawk take on the awakened Luffy?
We know that Mihawk is an overpowered swordsman,
and swords are basically Luffy’s main weakness.
But one thing you have to consider is that
Luffy would be showing off his Gear 5 powers
for the first time.
And just like we witnessed during the Wano
arc, seeing Gear 5 Luffy for the first time
can make anyone seem silly [show luffy jump
roping with Kaido in ch 1045].
So when Mihawk swings his giant sword, Luffy
blocks it with Advanced Conqueror's haki,
grabs Mihawk by the cape, and swings him around
like a little tornado [kinda like tasmanian
devil from looney toons].
Mihawk responds with a flurry of slashes,
but at this point the Whitebeard commander
Vista jumps in [similar to ch 561] so Luffy
can continue towards Ace.
Meanwhile, everyone watching this clash is
stunned.
Ace is shocked that his brother is so powerful.
The marines are in awe of this ridiculous
power that they have never seen before.
Even whitebeard, who out of everyone here
possibly knows that most about the void century,
can’t believe that this kid he has never
heard of has such insane powers.
As always, Luffy doesn’t care about what
others think, he is simply focused on freeing
his brother, no matter who stands in his way.
But first, let’s recap all of the powers
that Luffy didn’t have at the original Marineford
war [consider a checklist here].
He now has mastery over every form of Gear
4 such as Bound man, Tank man, and Snake man
that he learned while training with Rayleigh
during the time skip.
He also mastered Future Sight Haki during
his fight with the mochi man, Katakuri, and
in Wano he learned both Advanced Armament
while in prison AND advanced conquerors haki
during his fight with the Emperor Kaido.
On top of all that, during that same fight
with Kaido, he finally awakened Gear 5.
And while the Gear 5 powers can look goofy
at first, the awakened form of Luffy’s devil
fruit literally allows him to make his imagination
reality.
This explains his fire powers such as Red
Hawk and Red Roc.
And also the impossible ways he can bend his
body.
And since Luffy is THE MOST creative character
we have seen in One Piece, the possibilities
for his new powers seem almost endless.
With so many new powers, it seems like Luffy
should wipe the floor with everyone at Marineford,
right?
Not quite.
We also have to consider how the marines might
act differently if Luffy showed so much power.
First, we will assume that the admirals would
know at least Armament and Observation Haki,
and probably advanced armament since they
even seemed to show it when they blocked Whitebeard’s
shock waves at the original marineford [ch
564].
It is also extremely likely that the admirals
Aokiji, the Chilly fruit logia user, and Akainu,
the Magma fruit user, have unlocked their
devil fruit awakening.
While we don’t really know, we’ve already
seen what could be their awakened powers on
Punk Hazard, where they changed the landscape
of the island permanently [ch 658 or episode
583].
So while Oda wasn’t ready to reveal these
powers during the original war at Marineford,
it seems fair that the admirals would use
it now since we already know what awakening
is from Luffy.
Plus the admirals didn’t really consider
Luffy a threat back at Marineford, but this
time around he would be one of their main
targets.
As the battle fully begins, Luffy is confronted
by both Aokiji and the light fruit user, Kizaru.
Their combined powers should keep Luffy contained
for now.
But keep watching to see if they can actually
keep Luffy from freeing Ace.
But Luffy isn’t the only top-tier fighter
here or the only one with a broken devil fruit.
In a previous video about all the devil fruits
in One Piece, we talked about how Whitebeard’s
Tremor fruit has the power to literally destroy
islands.
And Akainu’s Magma fruit is confirmed to
be the most destructive devil fruit in the
entire story.
Well in this scenario, these two would still
clash just like they did in the original Marineford
[ch 567].
That leaves the other warlords like the string
fruit user, Doflamingo, and the shadow fruit
user, Gecko Moria, to fight against the Whitebeard
commanders and the prisoners from Impel down.
But this particular part of the battle is
much different now that Luffy is fighting
two of the admirals by himself, meaning Aokiji
and Kizaru cannot help fight against the Whitebeard
pirates.
So the warlords would quickly be overrun,
meaning that fleet admiral Sengoku would probably
order Luffy’s grandpa Garp and the cyborg
Pacifista to enter the battle to support the
marines.
Another important change would be that since
Whitebeard joined the fight earlier, Squard,
an allied captain of Whitebeard, never had
the chance to betray him [ch 562].
This means that Whitebeard would be even stronger
than we saw him in the original war.
Even the encircling wall that the marines
used as a trap would be meaningless because
Luffy could just punch his own holes in it.
So far, things are not going well for the
marines.
Which would definitely lead to Akainu doing
something desperate.
If the battle was going so poorly, I think
he would likely use his awakening to change
the battlefield into magma.
It would literally be like the floor is lava.
But the allies have ways to counter this.
Whitebeard could use his tremor powers to
make a tidal wave that would cool the magma.
Luffy could even use Gear 5 to do something
silly like blow super cold air onto the molten
rock.
Now, let’s jump back to Luffy.
While Aokiji and Kizaru have done a good job
keeping him busy, at some point I think the
Phoenix fruit user, Marco, who is the strongest
Whitebeard commander, would come to help him.
This would allow Luffy time to get away.
So Luffy would reach the platform where his
brother Ace is tied in chains.
The fleet admiral Sengoku is still waiting
for him here.
But with Luffy this strong I don’t think
the golden Buddah would be able to keep Luffy
from freeing his brother.
And with Luffy’s future sight, Kizaru wouldn’t
be able to snipe the key [ch 571], meaning
Luffy would set Ace free.
Then they just fly away and everyone is safe
right???
Hardly.
Freeing Ace was the easy part.
Now we’ll need to see if everyone can get
out alive.
While Ace is free, Whitebeard and Akainu have
both taken considerable damage.
Marco is struggling with Kizaru and Aokiji,
Garp, Mihawk, and the Pacifista are overwhelming
the Impel Down prisoners and the Whitebeard
commanders.
The pirates are beginning to break.
But with Luffy and Ace back in the battle,
everyone gets a giant boost in morale.
And Luffy can even show Ace his own fire powers
such as Red Hawk and Red Roc.
The allies start to return to their ships,
but just like the original in Marineford,
Akainu targets the reunited brothers.
Kizaru takes over fighting the Whitebeard
and Akainu confronts Ace and Luffy.
Akainu would probably tempt Ace with insults
just like he did in the original war, still
being the hot-head that he is would turn back
to fight Akainu.
But the admiral is still stronger.
He knocks Ace to the ground with a magma covered
fist then stands over him to land the death
blow.
But this time Luffy isn’t helpless.
Instead he appears behind Akainu, and with
a furious roar, punches a hole straight through
the magma man.
Damn, that was satisfying.
And while Ace died from a similar wound in
the original story, we don’t know if Luffy
can actually defeat Akainu even with his current
powers.
For example, Akainu could use future sight
and then morph his body around Luffy’s punch,
similar to what Katakuri did with his mochi
powers [ch 884].
Regardless, this would stop Akainu from killing
Ace and give Whitebeard enough time to arrive
and CRUSH Akainu with an ISLAND SHATTERING
PUNCH.
Which leaves Akainu laying on the rock in
a bloody heap.
Cracks form in the island as the brothers
and Whitebeard get away, joyfully laughing
because of their freedom.
But the battle still rages on.
And it’s now that the cruelest antagonist
finally arrives.
That’s right.
Blackbeard has joined the party.
With his haunting laughter echoing across
the field, Blackbeard and his new crew look
down on the battlefield.
Remember that Blackbeard was the cause of
this whole war when he captured Ace and brought
him to the Marines.
He did this to become a Warlord and gain access
to the underwater prison Impel Down so he
could gather a powerful crew from the imprisoned
criminals.
And he came to Marineford intending to kill
Whitebeard and steal his devil fruit.
Well this time around, things are completely
different.
Ace is alive.
Luffy is a monster.
And Whitebeard is no longer on death’s door.
So while it is certainly possible that Blackbeard
would see this situation and decide it isn’t
worth the risk, to keep things more interesting
let’s assume that Blackbeard chooses to
continue his plan.
He and his crew immediately focus on Whitebeard.
While Whitebeard might not be a walking corpse
like he was in the original battle, he has
still suffered a lot of damage fighting Akainu.
The Yonko and the darkness fruit user clash
and Whitebeard is almost defeated.
But then Ace and Luffy leap in front to protect
the old man.
At this point, Sengoku arrives, crushing the
Blackbeard crew just like in the original
war [ch 578].
This gives Marco time to come over and heal
Whitebeard, and unlike his usual brash attitude,
Ace begs Whitebeard to retreat so that he
can live.
Whitebeard agrees, and signals the retreat,
but only after adding one last insult to the
world government by proclaiming that the One
Piece is real [ch 576].
The marines are stunned.
The allied pirates pull back, ready to return
home with a complete victory.
But the battle is not done yet.
Akainu returns and continues to attack with
the full force of the other admirals, Because
at this point the marines are about to suffer
a humiliating defeat.
So even if Sengoku ordered the admirals to
stay back, Akainu would likely refuse to stop
because he can’t stand to let the Marine’s
honor be tarnished.
So the battle continues with Akainu trying
to take on the pirates by himself.
More lives are lost on both sides, and then
we get Koby’s moment of pleading to stop
the fighting.
At this moment, it is entirely likely Akainu
would not hesitate at all.
He could kill Koby in an instant, but let’s
assume that the last main player finally arrives.
Just like in the original war, Shanks shows
up to put an end to the fighting [ch 579,580].
This time however, Akainu goes all out at
Shanks.
He cannot stand to see another pirate making
demands of the marines.
And while we don’t know how this battle
would go, it is likely Akainu would be defeated
by the combined force of the Red Hair pirates
main officers.
And Akainu would only live if the other admirals
saved him by pulling him back..
At this point, there is no doubt Blackbeard
would retreat as he didn’t even want to
face Shanks in the original war.
But now we have an interesting situation.
Luffy and Shanks meet on the battlefield as
they protect the retreating pirates.
And Shanks would HAVE TO now fulfill the promise
he made back in chapter 1 and fully acknowledge
Luffy as a great pirate.
The Red Hair pirates cheer at the reunion
and there is laughter all around as the pirates
pull away from Marineford.
It truly is a complete victory for Luffy,
but one that leaves us with so many changes
to the story going forward.
Just listen to this.
Since Ace and Whitebeard are alive, we have
to consider what they would do next.
Whitebeard originally wanted Ace to become
the pirate king.
So after this battle it is possible that Luffy
and Ace would become rivals as they search
the New World for the One Piece.
On the other hand, Ace could say he doesn’t
want to follow in his father’s footsteps,
and he could support Luffy instead.
Shanks could also decide to go after the One
Piece, just like he chose to do at the end
of Wano when he first saw Luffy’s awakened
form.
So get ready for the race to find Laugh Tale.
But that’s not even close to the biggest
change that we will discuss at the end of
this video.
In fact, these changes at Marineford would
also mean that Blackbeard’s future is way
different.
Now he only has one devil fruit, and he might
not even know that it is possible to collect
two of them.
And after seeing Luffy’s powers, could Blackbeard
target Luffy to try to get his devil fruit?
Could we see them clash in the new world?
Or would Blackbeard struggle to even become
an Emperor since he doesn’t have Whitebeard’s
devil fruit?
But the biggest change would come within the
Straw Hats themselves.
At his current power level, Luffy definitely
wouldn’t need to train, so goodbye timeskip
[possibly dump volume 61 in the trash].
The Straw Hats would go straight through to
the new world with an overpowered Luffy leading
them forward.
Fishman island would be a breeze.
There would probably be no need to team up
with the warlord Trafalgar Law at Punk Hazard,
though they would likely still rescue Momonsoke
and Kin’emon, the samurai from Wano.
Dressrosa would be no contest as Luffy would
easily topple Doflamingo from his puppet throne.
However, not everything would be this easy,
particularly for the rest of the crew.
Since there was no timeskip, Zoro, Sanji and
other straw hats would be incredibly underdeveloped
as they never had two years to train.
If they were to be attacked by basically any
powerful enemy in the New World, Luffy would
need to save them all because they would not
be strong enough to protect themselves [show
rest of the straw hats being overwhelmed by
other characters.
King, Queen, Katakuri, Cracker, etc…]
Another interesting question is how would
the other Emperors react to Luffy’s power
in the New World?
They certainly wouldn’t underestimate him
again.
But would Kaido join forces with the clear
inheritor of the Joy Boy title?
Or would he and Big Mom team up even earlier
to search for the One Piece?
However it happens, the race to find Laugh
Tale would certainly start much sooner in
the story.
Let me know what you think would happen in
the comments below.
And while Luffy’s incredible powers might
be enough to bring the Straw Hats through
Whole Cake Island and Wano, it is equally
possible some of the straw hats could be defeated
or even killed.
One other factor is that if the war at Marineford
was successful, Luffy may never have matured
beyond where he was pre-timeskip.
The crushing defeat at the original Marineford
almost destroyed Luffy.
It forced him to grow up and train so that
he could be strong enough to protect his friends.
If none of that happened, then seventeen year
old Luffy could still be too immature and
eventually lead his crew into trouble later
in the story.
And this leaves us with another super interesting
question.
We saw that Gear 5 Luffy was able to save
Ace in the all out war at Marineford.
And this would likely make him the World Government's
number one target.
So we have to ask, what if Luffy was eventually
captured by the world government and set to
be executed just like Ace?
Who would come to save HIM?
In other words, what would happen if Luffy
was going to be executed by the marines?
Shanks for watching.